welcome everyone to the event
let me take a moment to get our live
stream started for our LinkedIn audience
that will take me about 30 seconds so
bear with me please
one of those things that
should be automatic but isn't
pretty and
we are live on LinkedIn and hopefully on
YouTube as well and I want to welcome
everyone to our event
which is
a digital marketing masterclass learn it
live with uh Matt Bailey the founder and
president of sitelogic marketing on how
to use on-page SEO to optimize your
content for higher rankings
you are watching through our live WebEx
chat
and enter questions from Matt into the Q
a box
we'll also be looking at the chat
uh best to put your questions in the Q a
and um
if you are watching on a streaming
service please put your questions in the
comments people who will relay those to
Matt
and
we'll also be asking you a couple of
questions so first I would like to start
with
uh simple question that'll give Matt an
orientation to who's in our audience
today
so the first part is how much work
experience do you have doesn't have to
be in digital marketing or SEO but how
much work experience do you have and
also uh check in on how you're doing
we've been asking this throughout the
the course of the pandemic and surges
come and go and as lockdowns open and
shut and so we want to make sure that
everybody's holding up
especially as we're hopefully turning
the corner on the pandemic and moving
into better days
and here is the result of the poll
and
interesting Matt do you have um
about 50 of the audience are either uh
students or recent graduates but we also
have about a third of the audience who
are people with more than 10 years
experience so wow
yeah both ends of the spectrum
um
and with that I'm going to introduce
Matt I'll let him speak more about
himself as I transfer control screen to
him but um just want to mention that he
is the president of sitelogic he is
a advisor to instructor with simply
learns digital marketing programs as
well as with the digital marketing
Association in New York
um a multi-author and we're extremely
fortunate to have him here today so let
me
turn it over to Matt give me a moment
sweetie
transfer control of the screen to him
all right thank you
and let me
all right I think we're good Stuart if
you can let me know if everything looks
good on your side it does
all right fantastic all right uh so it's
great to see so many people I I love the
uh the difference in the poll of people
just brand new into digital marketing
and those who have got the experience so
it's going to be a great mix of people
as we go through this and today's
session we're going to focus
on the on page optimization I love
on-page optimization because it's
everything that's under my control it's
everything I can affect or change
anytime I want and so that's why I love
on-page optimization now before I start
I've got something I would like you to
do if you've got your mobile handy or if
you can open up another tab on your
browser if you have a Google account go
to
myactivity.google.com now make sure
you're logged in all right and this is
just a a fun little activity I'm
starting to do at the beginning of
courses so that people can understand
exactly what is happening when you
search and I think in the back of our
minds we know that Google Tracks our
activity we know Google Tracks our
searches and keeps a record of it but
have you seen it and this activity if
you go to myactivity.google.com
you're gonna see everything that you've
done on Google
your searches the videos because YouTube
is a part of Google so any video
searches or videos you've watched
directions or anything like that now by
the way if you use an Android phone
Android is a Google operating system and
so you might also see the music you the
last song you listen to your song
history apps contacts anything like that
if you see something that is amazing uh
or let me just say if this is a shock to
you to actually see all of this in one
place put it in the chat let me know if
maybe there's a surprise there or uh put
in what the last thing you searched for
into the chat I'd love to see those pop
up uh while we're going through the
session here
all right let's talk about on-page SEO
as I said I love on page It's all under
my control but also the skills required
to do on-page SEO are the building
blocks for online marketing for every
different discipline because you're
working in keywords and without that
Foundation of keywords you can't
optimize on page and that enables you to
take that Foundation of keywords and
copywriting to using content marketing
to using digital ads to use in social
media it it crosses the boundaries and
it starts here all right and so we're
going to cover just the fundamental
factors we're going to try and do this
in 60 minutes all right as much as we
can to cover everything that we're going
to look at on page but I will let you
know this is just a broad overview of
what we can do in an hour there's a lot
more to it but this is the fundamental
factors that we're going to look at a
couple of things just for those of you
that are brand new to digital marketing
I'm going to be using a lot of
terminology the first one is keywords
now that's the words that people type
into the search box some people are
putting those up here in the chat
showing what are some of the last uh
searches that they did for their
electric company or for for a nearest
coffee shop or something like that you
could see those coming up there those
are keywords and we can learn what
people want by examining the keywords
the words that they type into that
search box
now the next is the algorithm now the
algorithm is what every search engine
uses to determine which sites are going
to rank at the top and which sites will
not and an algorithm is simply a set of
rules now there's probably thousands of
rules okay but it's rules or
calculations that are done by a computer
but a human has to write those rules all
right a human is the one who has to
create these rules and then arrange them
in a way to get the outcome that they
want once they're there then the
computer can take that and run that
through but that's what determines the
rankings but those rankings are all
based on a set of rules that a human put
together
now one of the things we're going to
refer to often is the serp and the serp
is an abbreviation of search engine
results page all right do you see where
that comes from it's an acronym for
search engine results page because this
is what we're concerned about this is
where we want visibility it's where we
want our rankings to happen because
after someone types in a search this is
what they see and this is where the
competition is
now how important is this just by being
on the front page you can see that the
percentage of people who see your
listing is dramatically higher than
being on the second page 94 of people
who do a search will see will get that
first page and as you can see the first
result gets about 35 percent of The
Impressions and then it it halves
immediately number two down to about 16
but once you start talking about the
second page or third page now you're
down in single digits of the amount of
people who will see that percentage-wise
so getting that those top spots will get
you the maximum visibility and that's
where we that's our goal in search
engine optimization
now it takes an understanding of knowing
how search engines work all right
there's a little bit of magic a little
bit of Art and a little bit of science
that's what I love about SEO you see at
this point when we're talking about
on-page optimization there are no
guarantees all right you do what you can
in on-page optimization you do what you
can in SEO and it affects the search
engines and and so it's a very indirect
relationship but by understanding how
search engines work will help us number
one
when you do a search online you are not
searching the live results all right
what I mean by that is the results that
you see come from a database and that
database is at a data center
and so if you search on Google what
you're actually searching is a database
of all the websites that Google has
collected
now they collect those through what's
called a crawl a spider a bot or a
crawler it's a software program that
just goes out and finds new web pages
and when it finds a web page it follows
the links and it downloads all the
information that's found there really it
duplicates the live web into the
database
because they can't run the algorithm
against the live results the the
information has to be contained in a
Data Center and the algorithm is run
against that so there's an element of
retrieval here that even though you
update the page it may not show up in
Google or Bing or any of the others
right away they have to get a copy of
that page bring it back see that it's
been updated and update their database
with the latest version
now once they've crawled your page and
they brought it back to their server now
you can see what Google has you can see
what any of the search engines has as I
highlighted here
um
if that little drop down you can see
something that's called cached all right
now that's the cash that is the version
of the page that the search engine has
on their server or in their database
this is also called an index all right
this is one thing I love about SEO if
you haven't picked up on this we have
three or four names for everything all
right a spider is also called a bot or a
crawler uh the cache or or the index the
database uh you know we've got three or
four names for everything so
the point is here you can see what is
indexed or what is in the search engines
database it's a good troubleshooting
mechanism if you're wondering if the
search engine has seen or indexed the
content of the page you can pull up the
cache as you can see here it's at it's
at Google and you can see the cached
version of the page to see what is being
seen what is available to Google
now once those are in the database then
the algorithm can be applied and that
gives us our organic results all right
the organic results those are what comes
out of the algorithm and then of course
we have our paid shopping ads all right
now those you go through Google ads you
add your shopping feed you build ads and
you pay for that ability to be at the
top of the page
but everything that is organic or
everything that we are optimizing for is
in the lower part of the page
now there are five primary factors that
I'm going to cover in this section and
then we're going to talk about secondary
sections secondary factors
the first five primary factors number
one page title meta description and then
we'll go into the headline subheadings
and then the links on the page
all right number one your page title
your page title is probably the most
important element of Optima on-page
optimization the page title if you're in
a browser is up here in the tab all
right the page title is not something
that shows up actually on the page it
shows up in the tab
the second thing is the meta description
Now The Meta description is interesting
because it does not affect your SEO
but it is important here's why
The Meta description can show up
in the search results the same thing is
the page title the page title let me
draw all this out here there it is
you see
these two elements are the two primary
factors in a Searcher deciding to click
on your page
that's why they're so important let me
bring this out let's talk a little bit
about this this is called the snippet
the snippet is the bit of information
that shows up in the search engine
results page all right and
in order to be fair in order to show
consistency in the results every website
is being conformed to this format and
this format is Page title
is usually in the large Blue text the
URL sometimes it's in green sometimes
it's in Black just depends on which
search engine or what they're testing
that day and then you have the
description
in the description is the content you
find underneath that and then also all
the search engines are starting now to
populate an image from the page so that
you can add more context now in context
of the search engine results page here's
where we can see this you see it doesn't
matter what website it is it doesn't
matter where it's coming from they are
all being displayed in the same format
and that is the snippet
all right that is what enables a
Searcher to view the content compare and
then decide what to click on
now let's dig into this a little bit
further here we've got I'm pulling out a
couple of Snippets and you'll notice
there's a couple of different things
here the number one result the number
one organic result you can see that's
Tom's guide to webtam webcams the number
one result also has links oh Isn't that
cool all right uh the number one organic
result has links and in those links they
are links to other Pages within the
website
now this enables users or Searchers that
even though I searched for webcam
reviews when I see these site links is
what they're called all right they are
called let me make that a little bit
better they are called site links
now Google will typically pull those
from your website and create those
automatically and so you can see here
we've got a link to best microphones uh
link to this webcam review a link so
specific webcam reviews and as you can
see those links are to pages that are
directly related to the search term
and you can see we've got our URL
page title
and description
now this is why it's so important to
work on these things the description may
not influence your rankings but the
description influences the Searcher when
they click on the result because they're
looking for information and will they
find that information in here
now here's something interesting about
the description we'll dig into this
so now we're looking at Tom's guide the
page and we are also looking at the
snippet we can see that the page title
shows up in the uh the browser in the
tab and it shows up down here now what's
interesting is when we then get to the
description now to the description we
can start looking around on here the
description we're going to pull into
this here because there's two ways that
Google gets that description onto the
page
two ways that that happens let's look at
it here so I'm going to look at one
let's let's pull apart this page here
here's another uh camera page and let's
break this down so there is the snippet
and there we're seeing the page title
dropped out of the browser and it shows
up there in the search results the URL
shows up like I said sometimes it's
green sometimes it's black all the
search engines are changing trying to
see what increases readability and then
we have this this is the description a
complete listing of stage divacicam's
reviews of digital cameras now that
content this sentence is not on the page
rather it is in the code and the code
there is a meta description and content
and you can put the description that you
want to show and so it may not be
content that's on the page it can be
content that's in this meta description
field and you can add that in there
that's one way of doing it the other way
is that Google or Microsoft or Bing or
any of the other search engines
instead of pulling content from The Meta
description they may choose to pull
content from the page
all right so actual content that you've
got on the page that has a keyword or
two that the Searcher used
so in this way they're going to try and
show the most relevant snippet or
context of information rather than rely
now if you don't have this meta
description they're going to use content
from your page if you do have the meta
description most likely they'll use that
but not always all right so that that's
that's the description there of how we
can work with that so it takes that code
and sometimes again what we're doing is
we're affecting we're not changing all
we can do is try and control this
process as much as possible and see what
Google does or what Bing does because we
are trying to influence they can't you
can't change exactly everything and
sometimes yes Google might change your
page title if they think you're being
too spammy if they don't think there's
enough content they may change your page
title for you
I don't like that I like to own as much
as I can on the page when we start doing
this now
how do you write a page title all right
how do you write a good page title that
will show in Google that's number one
number one for a page title is I want it
to show up
I want it to be readable
because I'm concerned about the user
what I'm trying to get is the click
that's my goal you see rankings is
secondary
all right I yes I want a good ranking
however
I want clicks
more than I want rankings do you
understand the difference there rankings
are great I I love a number one ranking
sure you know what I want more I want
clicks I want people coming to my site
because clicks mean money rankings don't
automatically mean money so now it just
so happens if I rank higher I might get
more clicks not always all right a lot
of that depends on what you're going to
see here now there's a number of ways to
write a title but here's my a couple of
things and maybe you've seen this where
uh you know a couple of formats are
keyword
comma keyword
comma keyword as a page title or maybe
you'll see a keyword and they'll use the
bar and then another keyword
I don't like those all right and the
reason why I don't like those I like
sentences
sentences that are quick and easy to
read and describe the content all right
look at this the best webcams in 2022.
weird and in fact you don't need 20
keywords in there you don't need five
keywords you just really need those two
best webcams all right I love this best
webcams 2022 top picks for working from
home so they put a context in it to get
you thinking about that uh but you can
see here it's best webcams best webcams
but yeah best of showing up all right
and and that's one of the words that we
see often that people are looking for
but be careful all right
my guide is I want a short clear
sentence that people can understand very
quickly and I also want them to be able
to see it on mobile
that's what I'm looking for so beware or
be aware of maybe your sentence is too
long and it won't be seen on mobile
results
so I'm usually shooting for about less
than 50 characters uh 50 or less
characters and by character I mean a
letter
or a space
that's a character the shorter it is I
want it to be readable very quickly both
on desktop and on mobile all right and
that increases the ability of people if
I'm just loading up keywords it's
actually not as readable as a sentence
our brains are wired for sentences so
don't stuff keywords in there clear
simple here's my number one rule tell
people what they will see or learn
that's it tell people what they will see
or learn when writing a page title
all right now the next three primary
areas and these primary areas are very
simple it deals with your content but
not just the writing of the content the
arrangement of the content how are you
going to show the content on the page we
do this through headlines subheadings
and I would also call this actions links
or text decoration what are you going to
do with it number one headline
there should be one headline per page
and I'm going to you know in HTML that
is the H1
all right and then your headline is in
here
and then you close that down
headline one headline per page why
because that's the way newspapers do it
that great uh This is How I Learned SEO
is I was actually in journalism when I
was developing websites and I developed
websites the same way I learned to lay
out a news page and then the news that's
what you learn one headline per page and
by that I mean the big headline the
number one thing that grabs your
attention that is the most important
thing on the page and everything else
should be smaller and less intrusive
subheadings
but there should be one headline one H1
per page now that's where you give the
reader the most important information up
front you tell them here's what you're
going to learn this is your primary
place to put keywords and by the way
putting a keyword into an H1
not only does it make the text bigger
Bolder and easier to read for a user it
also tells the search engine that the
content contained in this H1 tag in my
headline is the most important on the
page
so now we've got two very important
places to put keywords my page title and
my headline now some content Management
Systems will duplicate this so if you
put something into a headline it will
also make it a page title that's okay I
like to to add a little more context
maybe a few more words maybe position it
a little differently uh I don't want to
just simply repeat Prime content areas
this is your chance to tell people what
they're going to learn all right so also
write it an active voice uh what active
voice means is actively what are you
going to learn here's what's here uh
don't don't uh put unnecessary filler
words into your headlines or page titles
all right and avoiding Nuance that has
to do with sometimes be aware if your
keywords also have meaning in other
Industries uh sometimes people try to
play word games or uh uh maybe be
humorous by wordplay
search engines don't understand humor
all right and so be clear and be
specific about what you are saying now
when laying out your page like I said H1
is a headline that is the number one
there should only be one headline per
page
however we can have multiple subheadings
are noted by the H2
s the next largest headline on the page
and this helps you organize your content
H3 I usually use that as a paragraph
header and then H4 for captions or other
type of containers so what you can see
here is when I'm taking the text and I
am organizing it and I am using headers
or headlines or subheadings to show
here's the content that's going to come
after the reason why I'm doing this is
that I want people's eyes to follow the
path of content on the page you see our
brains are wired number one to look at
the area of highest contrast on the page
high contrast is big bold black letters
on a white background that is the
highest contrast that you can create and
so if my headline are is a big bold
black text on a white background that is
the first thing you're going to look at
and then naturally the eyes will scan
through the content and as they Scan
they pause to look at headlines
subheadings anything that's in a bullet
list and by the way if I bold the first
two or three words in a bulleted lists
you know look at it I can increase how
where the eyes go I can increase how
much content is viewed by simply using
these factors also anything that's
hyperlinked that's blue and underlined
people will look at that in a big bold
beautiful buttons that you want people
to press they will view that as well but
the eyes will scan through a page very
quickly number one to find out is this
the right place
does this page have the information that
I want
number two they're trying to sense
location if this is not the page what
are my options if it is the page what
can I learn and where is it and so by
again
using subheadings using bullet points
using all these things we can use
keywords to direct people to the right
place and the cool thing is when you use
H1s H2S h3s bulleted lists bold text
what you are also doing is telling the
search engine the words contained in
these elements are important
and so just by arranging the content now
some of you this might look familiar if
you did anything like this in school all
right and and Elementary or primary
school and this is the steps you learn
to write a paper number one what's your
main idea what's your objective and then
what are the three supporting areas so
my first content heading my second
content and so these are all maybe three
different paragraphs and in those
paragraphs I have content and so and
then the conclusion and so what I'm
doing is breaking up my content so that
I can have a paragraph header or a
subheading here's the key when we talk
about text on the page
people don't read they scan this is why
I'm focused on headlines because they
will scan the headlines but they will
not read text so if you have text on the
page that is more than three sentences
guess what
no one's reading it
in the modern internet
digitally if anything is longer than two
sentences it will not be read because
why it just looks like a big block of
normal text and no one's going to look
at that what they depend on is the
subheading to tell them what's in those
next few sentences
and so remember that that just simply
putting more text on a page
it's not really going to be effective
because people won't read that
all right so if you you can find a lot
of these tools in Firefox or uh even in
some in other browsers uh but what it
will do is show you the markup inside
the page so for example here's a great
example of a life hacker here's the H1
and here you can see it on the page now
what's interesting is they've got uh you
know H2 and you can see the structure uh
here's Nintendo switch Nintendo switch
and and you know H4 are all of their
share the story get our newsletter more
so you can see how they structure the
content on the page and we can see it
over here as well we can see it in
context of what's going on and how they
answer the questions
all right we're going to take a quick
break here in the middle uh Stewart's
got another pull he's going to wind up
here but on this subject I'm going to
invite you to subscribe to my podcast
endless coffee cup and we did an episode
uh me and T adeola osunubi we did an
episode on six SEO myths that don't go
away uh so you can get that on my site
uh sitelogicmarketing.com podcast SEO
myths or go to your podcast provider
search for Endless coffee cup uh and
we've got a number of scgo shows that
you'd be interested in all right Stuart
I hand it over to you for the next poll
okay I'm gonna switch screens for a
minute so I can put the poll up on the
screen all right and uh I'll switch back
to you in a moment but
oops sorry
here is our poll question
let me launch the poll for the people on
WebEx
so Matt would like to know what's your
least favorite part of SEO
and by contrast what's your favorite
part of SEO
give you another 20 seconds or so to
answer the question
in about 10 seconds we'll close the pool
and people's least favorite activity is
the programming and technology behind it
that's not a surprise but their favorite
activity is on-page optimization and
keyword research so yeah all right great
great audience I think that may be
because the audience self-selected for
that today
um with that I'm going to uh
transfer the screen sharing back to you
all right
all right and we're back thank you
Stuart that is great information
um yeah programming for some reason yeah
that's uh
I think because that just gets into a
hornet's nest of uh there's so many ways
you can go with that and and maybe we
should consider that as a future uh
webinar is dealing with the programming
behind the scenes
um so absolutely thank you all for
participating in that and so we're gonna
hit the second half of the session here
and then we'll take your questions uh
but yeah we can go much more into SEO on
some of the podcast episodes if you have
a chance I would appreciate it and look
forward to seeing you on the
conversation all right
now let's get into some secondary
ranking factors secondary on-page
factors number one is the content itself
all right
how you write the content and it's a
matter of writing efficiently to
describe to help people solve problems
uh you also want them to understand
where to go now there is a fine line
especially when it comes to using links
within your content to link to other
Pages now those can be Pages internally
on your own website or externally on
someone else's website so like for
example
um and this content here we have a link
and they refer to Google's advanced
search page that is an external link
great because you are explaining
something and then you're showing
someone here's what I'm talking about
they can click on it and go see
um same thing if I am talking about uh
another brand and I want to show people
hey go look at that brand page putting
those links in there the external links
are great it helps people get that
resource now once in a while you can
also put links to your own content but
there is a a warning to that
doing that too much linking to your own
site within a page of content too much
can trip a a trigger that it might be to
spammy because that is a tactics that is
used by people trying to inflate their
rankings by putting in a lot of links
the rule is do it when it's helpful do
it when there's a call to action but
don't link every subject don't link
every word to another page in your
website it actually will and and part of
it is just look at the page look at the
page when you're done does it look good
is it attractive will it make someone
want to read it if it's full of 20 links
people aren't going to read that because
it will look spammy and by spammy I mean
it's one of those things with in the
industry they call it the black hat the
um it's just more I would call it more
of an unprofessional approach because
you're trying to inflate your rankings
through
basically gaming tactics so look at what
you're doing and look at the
professionalism of it you're trying to
reach people first but the focus of our
content is to give people answers
think about it in terms of and maybe
some of you are doing this if you have a
smartphone if you have a voice assistant
how do you search on that most people
will use a question for an example here
I've got this search here of how to make
a latte that's how people are searching
more and more is they're asking those
how to where is where do I find uh how
does this work things like that people
have questions and as you can see here
this content that is showing up at the
top of the page is an answer and so we
can develop content on our pages in a
question and answer format and you can
also see that shows up here uh and and
this is especially helpful when you see
other questions that people ask
because it gives you a sense of the
questions they're asking and do you have
that content on your page if so then or
if not then start integrating that think
about the questions people ask this is
what keyword research is all about it's
not just finding what keywords people
use but it's finding the context of
those searches and the intent what do
they want to know when they use those
words that's what optimizing the content
is all about
now another thing we need to take into
consideration is the URL structure a
clear path and this is where people use
this as far as where am I on the site uh
you know you can get to a long thing
here we grab the URL of one of the sites
we're looking at here
um but you can have keywords in there so
here we have news Computing peripherals
webcam now a lot of your CMS systems
especially WordPress if you're using
Wordpress will take the page or the post
title that you added and it will make
that the URL which is good it's you know
it's a nice way to make that happen you
don't have to think about it but think
about your url structure this is one of
those programming issues that used to be
a problem years ago but I don't see it
as much now mainly because especially
WordPress is like 40 percent of the
internet uh and it helps you build
better URLs that are more understandable
to humans and to search engines all
right those are our two audiences here
and we can't forget that next thing is
the alt attributes buy an ALT attribute
this is when you add an image you are
asked about the alt attribute or the
title attribute or both the alt
attribute describes the image that if
the image doesn't load what are people
going to be able to read now this has
its roots both in accessibility but also
in connectivity
what I mean by that I mean if people are
using Voice assistance in order to
browse the internet maybe there is a
vision issue or some use it for other
reasons as well
that if the image doesn't show they can
hear what that image is supposed to show
they can get a context for it the other
side of it too and maybe some of you
that are on commuter trains or anything
where you only have a one bar and the
page loads but some images don't load if
those images are critical to the content
the critical to the navigation
what happens if they don't load so your
alt attribute describes the image what
is it that's being shown and does it
help the user now that there's also a
title attribute for every image and that
title really just describes a little bit
more
um it's more the the the purpose of the
image placeholder image uh is it a
product image you're just explaining
that the purpose of it the alt attribute
is what the search engine is going to
look at in order to evaluate what's the
image about
all right and also file names anytime
you link internally I see this all the
time
um if I'm linking to an image if I'm
uploading an image if I'm uploading a
PDF or anything like that what do you
call it so for example
um you know if I've got a file name
about how to set up your email okay I
can call it email setup.pdf
great so when I link to it I'm actually
using a keyword that explains what it is
however uh if I'm on a page I could also
say learn how to set up your email
account and I can link to to that PDF so
in that way I'm describing what people
will get
and I'm linking to the document that has
the name in it as well so anytime I'm
uploading anything I look at both the
file name
or the page name that's where we also
will look at how are we naming Pages
images PDFs any other media that you are
uploading first what is the name the
file name itself
uh I usually see like especially images
if it's taken with a digital camera or
something it's like dscc 111 a bunch of
numbers rename it all you have to do is
Click rename and give context to it all
right and that's a lot of what SEO is
all about it's not one or two or three
things that are going to get you to the
top of the rankings it's a thousand
things a thousand small things that
accumulate and build context and the
more context you have the more the
search engine can see those threads of
how everything is interrelated and that
you have built a a strong narrative or
context for this content and that's how
you gain those rankings
all right next micro formats this is an
increasingly important
subject and increasingly important for
content on your page now I'm putting
this resource up in the corner here if
you want to know more about micro
formats there are hundreds of them now
what is a micro format a micro format is
an accepted data structure
across the internet and by that I mean
browsers operating systems
uh search engines apps
anyone who is developing content or
managing information online
they have all agreed on this schema and
you can find it at schema.org and what
it is is an accepted data format that
will be translated uh on any type of
device or browser or computer
what do I mean by that here's a great
example if I have a calendar event I can
use this micro format all right that
says here's the element here's the start
and time where is it where's the title
contact information now if I have an
event coming up yes I can program that
in HTML but if I use the micro format
automatically if Google sees this
content on the page it knows it is a
calendar event and it can publish it in
the results as a calendar event
in your mobile device if you see this in
an email or see it on a web page your
mobile device will recognize it as a
calendar event and you can add it to
your calendar
you see it's a multi-function content
thing and so here is an on schema.org
you will get the code you can download
the code for
an event not only that let's look at a
review so your reviews can employ micro
format schema data as well and so you
know here's what it looks like on the
page but then we can show here's what it
looks like in schema markup
so that way if I have these reviews on
my web page Google sees them Google will
translate those as reviews and also
incorporate it into their search results
all right so this is the power of micro
formats uh and not only Google but Bing
can do it because they're using the same
data that is the power of this and then
also I can write articles on my site
using this using the H entry micro
format and the H entry is really just a
code for markup about an article and
then an author tag as well
these enable your content to be
understood across Data Systems across
operating systems browsers it interprets
the information
across all data all right and this is
one of those things that Google has
mentioned this over the years but it's
one of those things that people have not
picked up on much at all and they
there's very very slow adoption
but Google keeps saying how important
micro formats are and it just doesn't
seem to be being picked up I think
because it's part of that programming
that people don't like so that is
another area to develop and look at and
see how you can employ schema on your
content
when I look at a page to see how
optimized it is this is kind of that
checklist I'm number one I'm looking at
did you use a keyword in the URL
um now sometimes I'll look at the number
of hyphens in the URL uh it less and
less is that becoming important mainly
because with WordPress as people develop
page titles uh or or headlines we're
starting to see like a bunch of hyphens
and I don't think it's a problem as much
of a problem as it is anymore however I
still review that URL because if there's
20 keywords all separated by hyphens
that can be a problem uh what's the
navigation look like on the page are you
using keywords there what's the H1 and
then where are your subheadings how do
those subheadings help people move
through the page are there related
keywords are there questions on the page
to help drive people to the answer that
they want these are all the things that
I'm looking for when I read review a
page to make sure on page you've done
everything you need to do before you go
to the next part of optimization which
is building links and honestly making
sure your site structure is correct and
that gets into the programming and
technical issues that we don't like
dealing with but maybe we'll address
that in the future
all right Stuart I have reached the end
of my part uh in the presentation but we
have time to take questions and I have
seen a lot of questions come up
um it for everyone uh stay tuned for the
questions because this is good stuff but
you can connect with me on LinkedIn I am
Matt Bailey uh site logic uh and also
the endless coffee cup podcast or pick
up the teach new dogs old tricks on
Amazon
super
there we go so
let's get to some of the questions
um Mark asks an interesting question I
can't help but feel like SC has a rich
man's game is it true that in order to
get to the top of scrp we have to have
high quality content that have to pay a
lot of money for expert content writers
and is it really worth it
wow great great question
um I mean Mark it's a it's a it's a
there's two things money and time all
right
um you know I
that's the thing I I struggle with that
all the time it's either I have to spend
the time writing it or I have to pay
someone to do it
um and so those are the two things we
have to deal with now if you're the
expert yeah you're going to be doing the
writing um but you also have to learn
how to write well and write for
presentation presentation on a mobile
phone presentation on a desktop how's it
going to look how are people going to
read it so
number one is the expertise number two
is the writing expertise in that subject
or the expertise in the subject number
two is the writing ability number three
is the ability to make it look good and
desirable uh and then we have to look at
the the call to action what are you
asking people to do so there are a
number of factors that go into creating
that content and so yes in in some ways
yeah it it you've got to have money or
time uh to do these things and uh so in
a lot of ways I I would say that it's
probably about 60 yes I would answer
that question okay
um
we have a question about whether UTM
tracking affects scrp
not at all
um well UTM tracking is typically for
you know your ads
um UTM is typically where you'll append
ads I don't usually UTM append
uh my web pages though
um because that will show up in the
analytics anyway
uh so I will only use UTM codes on paid
campaigns uh on emails on external
things like that I don't use it for just
regular web pages uh it shouldn't it
shouldn't affect anything
um but I I really don't typically use it
on pages and and I'm not sure
um I think you just might be adding more
information than is necessary to track
individual Pages whereas campaigns
absolutely
okay uh vinay and remask two questions
that are related uh vinay's question is
how well or accurately does SEO work for
small-scale businesses and then rheem's
question related is a company needs to
increase its presence how do you do that
with SEO all right I'll take a small
business first because that's number one
if I'm a small business the first thing
that I'm doing is I'm going to Google my
business
Google my business is the number one
thing you should do if you have a local
business claim your business listing
then get in verify all the information
correct what needs to be corrected add
what needs to be added and
then stay in that listing you should be
getting into that Google my business
listing at least once a week if you're
the business owner you can get an app on
your phone uh because people can message
you from the business listing and Google
Tracks the response time
business listings that have a great
response time get listed higher business
listings that have complete information
in their profile get listed higher
business listings that add lots of
photos that add lots of information
Google will even prompt you to blog on
your Google listing all right the more
active you are in the Google my business
listing the more you get rewarded uh and
then they've got great analytics to see
how many times has it been shown what
are people searching for so you see what
searches your local listing is coming up
for
um I've got a lot of local businesses
that I work with
um they're getting more business through
their business listing page or through
their business listing on Google then
the actual rankings on Google so for a
small local business it's your game get
in it and you can make the biggest
impact right there
for a small business or anyone else
doing SEO absolutely uh SEO can help you
uh and and that's one of those things
that is a cumulative effect as you start
implementing SEO number one you're going
to be using keywords the right words to
reach your audience so right away it's
going to make your content more relevant
to the reader you'll be answering their
questions you'll be using the right
words and so you will see a boost in the
rankings but you'll see another boost in
the visitors that are on your page
they're they're going to be seeing more
relevant content then over the weeks the
months as you add more content as you
build links as you it kind of it's it's
like attention once people start
noticing then they start talking and
then you start to see those results but
SEO is not an overnight thing very rare
cases does it have happen overnight I
could talk you know there are some
actors there but that's usually for an
existing company that has content that's
been around for years and they've never
done SEO but once they do it wow but if
you're a new business just starting out
there's three elements to SEO number one
is how well your site is built uh the
language that's used the structure
that's why you know WordPress I love it
it helps you with that number two is the
on-page content that we just covered
number three it's the incoming links
from other websites and that is all
about link building and PR to get people
to link to you uh and that's why we do
content marketing and those types of
things to build those links but those
are three Essential Elements you can't
have rankings without those three
Tracy asks
um your thoughts on improving CTR a
company that has a hundred thirty
thousand Impressions and only 50
visitors
what are ways that they can change that
ratio all right
um boy that is great great question okay
so here's the thing uh do we have a
whiteboard in here that we can use uh
yeah I think
um I'll give you the sharing privilege
so you can do that all right
should be one of the things that you're
allowed to share is your whiteboard
all right I don't know if I have
ah there we go no whiteboard sure
awesome okay
now here's the thing we're talking about
Impressions oh I've got to use their pen
okay
all right
oh it's
okay I have to learn this it's a new
system
um your pointer text tool
pen there we go all right and wow
okay now impressions are at the add
level all right so that means I have
written an ad
and the number of people that see the ad
is the impression all right so they just
see it
now to get the click
all right if I see that I've got a lot
of Impressions so as you said something
like 150 000 Impressions but only 50
clicks all right that tells me that
there is a problem here
all right what is in between the
impression and the click it is the
number one is the message
what are you saying in the ad are you
solving a problem are you addressing a
pain Point are you uh reaching someone
with a relevant message that's the
biggest thing if I see a big disparity
between the amount of people that see it
and act on it
that number one right there is the
message and the message is communicated
through the headline
and the image
those are your two primary elements to
convince someone to take action now
after the click they come to the page
and then once they're on the page I want
them I have a goal now that goal could
be a form it could be
it could be a checkout or something like
that and so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to track how many people clicked
how many people see the page how many
people check out or buy or fill out a
form and I'm going to watch these
numbers all the way through because they
tell me where the problem is if I'm
getting a lot of Impressions and maybe
let's say I'm I'm getting up now to 250
clicks however I'm only getting you know
maybe five sales well the problem then
is my page because that's what's in
between it's what am i showing them what
I'm asking them to do is it clear is it
easy to understand so you've got an
issue in between the impression and the
click and that is your creative
what are you asking people what's your
promise what's the pain point
great that's a great explanation
um we have a question from the YouTube
audience about what's the impact of the
recession related to that as a question
about where in the world
how can I ask where in the world digital
marketing hasn't picked up
uh as a as a discipline or as a
a way of doing business
interesting
um because of kovid and the subsequent
recession it SEO has emerged as one of
uh I would say forgotten discipline SEO
has gotten much more attention over the
past two years because people have
relied on finding businesses finding
products finding what they need online
and all of a sudden everyone starts
remembering SEO
um because social is not a good search
mechanism when you want something you go
to Google which is why had you do that
exercise up front to see what do you
search on how often do you search what
are you looking for as popular as social
is
search traditionally has always been 60
to 70 percent of visits traffic and
attribute attributable conversions
search is the number one I mean Google's
the number one two and three Media
company in the world uh Google Google
ads and YouTube all right so when people
need something they go to search and SEO
is the way to capitalize on that so even
though you know we have the question is
is there a rich man's game sometimes
other times you know now it's a rising
and certain people are jumping ahead
because they've got great content in the
way that people want to see it and
they're able to communicate it
effectively that's what SEO is all about
okay
uh Jawad asks a question what's your
opinion on AI writing I'm assuming he
means AI generated content
uh good question good question I have
seen
terrible AI writing and I've seen fairly
good AI writing um put it this way I may
let AI write but I'm not gonna press
that publish button uh I'm gonna look at
anything AI writes uh and review it and
and but I'll give you a great example I
I doing webinars like this if we want to
create a transcript I will use an AI
service to take the audio and create a
transcript I always have to review the
transcript
um computers don't always detect Nuance
uh they don't always detect rhyming
words that sometimes you say a a phrase
that gets turned into something else so
AI you know it's it's another one of
those things great great idea amazing
promises being made I have yet to see it
do it perfect
we have an interesting question from an
anonymous user
can you place competitor names in your
meta keywords and expect to get
visits or hits when people search their
name
meta keywords have not been used by
search engines since about
2003 or 2004.
I don't even mess with meta keywords
anymore
um it used to be we would put
misspellings sometimes we would put
competitor names
the keywords because it's it's not seen
it's not helpful it's not uh anything
like that
um the best way to do it is to if you
want to legitimately about this make a
competitor comparison chart what does
this competitor offer that you what
don't they offer that you do and that
way you're actually getting their name
on the page you're getting the product
name on the page you're getting the
benefits and features and you're lining
them up against yours and showing that
so in that way that is a legitimate
comparison uh no one can come after you
legally unless you're you know not being
truthful right in that way you're
presenting a competitor side by side
against you and and that it's a
legitimate way of creating good content
Thatcher asks a question uh he's
recently read that PPC ads can damage
page rank so if that were true would it
make sense to drive PPC adds to a
different landing page or use a sub
domain
for PPC landing pages
um paid search and organic results are
are two different worlds
um now when I create a paid search
campaign I will always use a specific
landing page I will create one for my
paid campaigns
you do it's usually a best practice
to create a specific landing page for ad
campaigns and have your website for
organic it's not going to damage it's
just a matter of best practice if I'm
paying
for ads
and I want someone to go to a specific
page I'm going to create that page that
page is going to have limited navigation
because I don't want them to leave the
page is going to be built specifically
to sell or to capture that lead and so
it doesn't need all of the stuff your
web page has it should be focused
firmly focused only on what you want
someone to do as a result of that ad uh
so in that way it's it's just more best
practice it doesn't harm you
um but your web page has a lot of stuff
that's just not necessary for a a
dedicated landing page
um we're running over time and we have
so many questions but I do want to ask
one last one and then I'll remind
everyone that they can uh reach out to
you through your different uh channels
on LinkedIn and other uh social media
but
uh we had a couple of questions that
came in uh here's a typical version
um I have my own business but I have no
website
um so how do I rank if I have
if I don't have that presence and the
other question sort of related to that
is
can you still do Google my business if
you're a virtual
business if you if you don't have a
brick and mortar presence you can yeah
you can use Google My Business Without a
website so yes
um yeah get in there go see what you
could do but absolutely yes you can
still do that
um I would but here's what I would
recommend just get a page up
um I A lot of times when I'm dealing
with companies or people it's it's we
don't have the budget we don't we can't
create a whole site
um everything
just get one page one page your business
what you do your contact information a
form just something up there worry about
the 20 30 page website when you can
afford it just start with just what you
need and get it up there that's it so
that you can be found for your business
name that's the most important thing
um too many times people get wrapped up
in oh you know we need a 50 page website
and design and no no no just do what you
need when you can deal with it then grow
thank you
perfect
so with that I'm going to get into the
final part of our webinar closing out
but I do want to remind everybody you
can find Matt on
LinkedIn put that link into the chat but
you can also subscribe to this endless
coffee cup podcast and find
his books on Amazon other booksellers
let me put into the chat at LinkedIn
URL so you can find them and then with
that I'm going to move on to
another quick poll of the audience
this poll is
what are the digital marketing skills
that you want to add to your toolkit
give you about 20 seconds to answer that
and also when do you want to start
learning those new skills adding them
um
we always said that if something is
going to improve your life and your your
career in
it's always worth doing sooner than
later but
and it's always a matter of whether you
can fit it into your
Uh current lifestyle schedule so here's
the poll results
and uh
not surprising that SEO is the most
popular answer
with social media
uh content marketing and a few others
email marketing as well so and it's good
to see that almost half the audience or
people who want to learn right away or
are learning right now
so let me
mention real quick uh
we have a program rest of the world it's
called professional certificate program
in digital marketing in the US
specifically it's called the digital
marketing boot camp
it runs through Purdue University Matt
is one of the advisors for it
um it has a comprehensive curriculum
covers all of the different skills that
are in that last poll uh in various ways
and it's a six-month program it requires
you to dedicate about 10 maybe 15 hours
a week actually rather than five to ten
but it has live classes that meet online
weekends around evenings depending on
what cohort you're in it gives you
integrated case studies and projects
that you do on in the online platform
it allows you to put together a final
Capstone project to solve an
industry-based
um digital marketing problem and be able
to show that to potential and future
employers
um
gives you access to the Purdue
University Alumni Association
uh it also gives you master classes from
meta from
Purdue faculty members and some
certificates also issued by meta so this
is a
one of our top digital marketing
certification programs
um
again it covers a whole lot of different
skills tools platforms subjects and
just out of curiosity because we know we
haven't described this in any detail but
I would like to know
um if folks in the audience
are interested in learning more about
that and I'll let you know how you can
find out more so
quick pull
and it's really not called the
postgraduate program anymore we've
changed it to uh
the two different names domestically the
digital marketing boot camp
domestically in the U.S and
internationally India and the rest of
the world
um it is the professional certificate
program
both
similar programs from
we learned in Purdue University
but here's the Polaris levels
and I will share with you how you can
learn more about the program about 78 of
the audience almost 80 percent of the
audience
are interested in finding out more so
what I will do is
including the chat how you can contact
us
regarding that so
now with that we're basically at the end
of our presentation I would love to let
everybody know
to contact
simply learn our social media channels
at simply learn Facebook or
on Twitter we're also simply learning on
LinkedIn I've given you Matt's contact
information and he shared with you uh
his podcast information
and uh
in the chat right now is the email
address ask us at
simplylearn.net which is how you can
inquire about our programs but you can
also visit us at our website of course
simplylearn.com
and also put into the chat
a quick link to the
Purdue University program that I
mentioned so you can see our website for
that
with that I want to thank Matt for being
so generous with his time and his
knowledge today
um appreciate it Matt
absolutely Stuart thank you again always
a pleasure
and I want to thank everybody who is
with us today both uh on WebEx and on
our streaming services
for joining us and we
hope to see you at future webinars but
we hope even more to welcome you into
the simply learned learning community
with that let's include our webinar
thank you